all right it's time for drew's news come
dip your chip in our good news salsa
and with me at the desk with my crusty
co-pilot ross matthews
hi oh and our one and only dear friend
is back he is a football legend and a
wfa and sports radio host it's none
other than
tiki barber
[Applause]
i need ross to go oh oh believe me i can
do it
i've been practicing
i love it well i can't think of two
better gentlemen to have this discussion
with and you may take the lead on it
however this is when i get all hot and
bothered of course two big football
games this sunday and this is really
down to it four teams two are going to
the super bowl this past weekend i have
to say was the best weekend of football
i think in the history of time
it was pretty exciting yeah
they all came down to the end they all
came down to last second place so in the
in the in the playoffs we have left
bengals versus chiefs okay and we have
the 49ers versus the rams
come on i want to know let's bro out who
is going to win though tiki what are
your predictions
the kansas city chiefs are hosting their
fourth straight afc championship game
so i'm going to pick them
they barely squeaked in though yeah but
the bills are really good yeah they lost
that was one of the greatest games i've
ever seen forget playoff games but the
bills and the chiefs last weekend was
one of the best football games you'll
ever experience they scored 25 points in
less than two minutes unbelievable and
then it went to overtime and whoever won
the the coin toss won the game and that
was the kansas city chief so i'm going
to pick the chiefs at home against the
bengals and then the nfc is a little bit
challenging
and i have to default to the better
quarterback so i'm going to go rams even
though i think the 49ers could win so
chiefs rams that's what i'm thinking
also i didn't realize that one of the
teams lost on a coin toss yeah well i
mean
that would really bill's in the chief's
game
it came down to who could score last
yeah whoever wins the coin toss
generally wins the football game
especially when it's like that i don't
like that i think they should
synchronize swim if there's a tie they
get in the pool whoever can do the best
thing
that's it
first up um into our stories we've got
more on
julie
is that how you say it i guess that's
how you would say it yeah
yeah
the total meta art project
walking fashion spread slash romance
between kanye west and actress julia fox
people reports that julia posted this
pic of kanye giving her a retouch
captioning it want to know who my
favorite makeup artist is
the two made their red carpet debut in
an all denim let's call it what it is
it's a canadian tuxedo
at paris men's fashion week julia says
kanye revamped her entire look and get
this he boxed up all of her old clothes
and got rid of them
[Music]
that this is moving real fast
yeah it's a slight little it's a little
mm-hmm it's a little weird okay it's a
little the the part the cute they did
her makeup that's cute okay all right
cute fun throwing away all her clothes
try it try it you come to michael try it
kanye
what
okay rocky don't worry all right next up
you know i love being here with you drew
every single day i found my dream job
but for those of you out there still
looking you're in luck newsweek reports
you could get paid to work from home
doing what i do
every day which is watching reality
dating shows and i'm proud of
it give me a page listen to this the
offer the office is so good drew i might
just have to take a side hustle it's a
dating app called palm they're gonna pay
you
135 dollars an hour for some lucky souls
to watch love island usa which is great
or the bachelor which is iconic and uh
you got to share some dating do's and
don'ts that you learn along the way so
um i wanted to ask you yes because
reality television is a way of life for
me yeah i watch it a lot not a lot of
people will admit it but a lot of you
are doing it okay i watched the bachelor
my former teammate is the host jesse
palmer yeah and there you go i can i
could apply for this job
and
am i right in saying that we're going to
be seeing
you on some reality tv um you might be
seeing my wife mm-hmm and me and you on
the real housewives of new jersey
[Applause]
one disclosure yes what don't judge us
for the crazy uh okay
right back at you
[Applause]
but i am curious is there drama it's
their drama yeah do you not watch
housewives oh please do you know who
you're talking to personally no there's
drama okay that's what makes it fun oh
for sure
oh drew all right
this is so exciting we're very excited
for this venture we're here for it and
we want you to come share it with us
[Music]